you know who doesn't look a thing like
RL Stein Jack Black just say it's
official they make a movie about my life
Chris Hemsworth gets to play me because
apparently you can choose people who
look nothing like you so that's what I'm
doing
step up from Jack Black but that's just
how I roll I was way out of control -
taking you back to the 90s goosebumps
was a series of books by author RL Stein
were like pretty much like Twilight Zone
or Outer Limits for kids they were scary
but they were meant for you so kids
would have nightmares but not you know
scar you for life nightmares everyone
was having a good time a lot of kids
read these books but this movie
goosebumps isn't really an adaptation of
any one story from goose bumps in
goosebumps this kid moves to a new
neighborhood he's in a new high school
his neighbor he has a crush on the
daughter but the dads Jack Black you
know he's really close I guess from my
house he's a really crimini guy you
don't really know why so he sneaks into
the houses all these goosebumps
manuscripts he opens one up and voila
the abominable snow monster comes out of
the book and in this so that's the
premise of this movie is you open up a
book and the goose bumps villains from
those Goosebumps books actually come to
life in our role it's kind of like think
Jumanji so that is a big adventure
happening because these kids and Jack
Black have to put all the monsters back
into the book somehow and they
surprisingly enjoyed this video that was
gonna be garbage I enjoyed this movie
for what it was it's not to say it's due
to any one character who is moving me
Jack Black's representation of Arkell
spine it's completely over acted I don't
know why he wanted to talk like a super
villain but it sounds like Jack Black
doing the super villain he's like yes
you must get him back in my books one
kid I did like is the main kid's friend
that he meets in high school I believe
it was that kid from super 8 if it
wasn't super 8 I'll correct it right
here but I believe he was from super 8
the kids dorky he's funny is what can I
say I just think dorks are cool a funny
nerd in high school my god it's like
looking in a mirror I swear to god that
was me in high school oh really what I
liked about this movie is the adventure
aspect I like the fact that these story
characters are popping out of this book
and into the real world and I love the
fact that this is all being headed up by
the ventriloquist dummy which is the
most famous goosebumps villain ever this
is a great thing to come out now you see
kids are gonna have a good time with
this movie it's going to be adventurous
it's going to be scary but not too scary
for them it's gonna feel dangerous like
they're kind of getting away with it
like yeah we're totally watching
something burn as opposed to so they're
going to be loving it luckily their
parents probably read goosebumps when
they were
it so they're gonna be like oh my gosh I
remember that feeling oh my gosh I
remember that I'm like I remember these
things it's gonna be a big nostalgia
bomb for the parents so family night
will come together go to the movie
theater watch goosebumps and have a good
time guys this isn't a groundbreaking
movie or anything like that I'm not
saying it is I'm just saying it is
Jumanji Lite for sure it's the diet coke
of Jumanji it's the gobots of Jumanji
even though it's the low calorie taste
of Jumanji
I enjoyed it not as much as Jumanji but
enjoyed it there's been a lot of
family-friendly adventures that have
come out in the past few years that I've
seen as I've been reviewing and not all
of them laying I felt like this hit a
sweet spot I feel like kids are gonna
love this movie and parents might
actually enjoy it too but if your kids
are looking for an adventure take him to
it I will say goosebumps is a good time
no alcohol required I would certainly
hope so
don't give your kids booze that would
make you a douche right so goosebumps
have you seen it what did you think
about it if you read goosebumps when you
were a kid what was your favorite
goosebumps story it's the ventriloquist
dummy I know whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you